I am such a fan of the first two
Sherlock Holmes movies do you think that
there's ever going to be a third one or
is it sort of that time has come and
gone well honestly I left this up to
Robert
so Robin wanted to be in charge of this
um so it's uh that the ball's in his
court so he's in charge of the script
he's in charge of the whole thing so
I've I've Moon walked out of that until
uh until there's a time for me to get
involved same question with the Aladdin
I obviously it's the biggest hit of I
believe your career
um it made like over a billion dollars
do you do you actually see yourself
doing a sequel I'd very much like to I
can't tell you how much I enjoyed that
experience
um it was a great experience uh and that
whole Disney thing as you can imagine is
is such a it's such a professional
outfit just from that perspective it was
so much fun I would I would I would very
much like to we'll we'll wait and see we
have been kicking some ideas around for
some time now but uh it'd be great to do
it'd be great to go back there yeah